history is filled with short-lived
nations those which appeared from
nowhere attempted to forge a place for
themselves in the world and then
promptly died Rhodesia are mostly
unrecognized Africa nation was one such
example which managed to eke out an
existence of 14 years which obviously
raises the question why was Rhodesia
such a short-lived nation and what
happened to it so a quick overview by
1964 South Rhodesia named after the late
19th century explorer Cecil Rhodes was a
British colony in the UK government was
painfully aware of its empires coming
collapse in Africa now many of Britain's
colonies there were administrated by a
white minority in Rhodesia was no
different the London government under
Prime Minister Harold Wilson said that
decolonization would only be granted on
the condition of majority rule as of
1964 Rhodesia operated on a system of
what's called responsible government
which was centred in the city of
Salisbury nowadays called Harare it had
its own prime minister and could control
its own internal affairs with some
British oversight its prime minister was
a man called Ian Smith who wouldn't
grant the franchise based upon race but
offered to granted based upon wealth
which was basically the same thing since
the wealth of Rhodesia was almost
exclusively controlled by the white
minority which made up 8% of the
population negotiations over this went
nowhere and Smith's government declared
independence Britain immediately
petitioned the UN to dissuade other
nations from recognizing Rhodesian
independence and it also began an
economic embargo and this most notably
included an oil embargo and led to
Britain implementing a nine-year
blockade of a Mozambique port here
through its Rhodesia was importing oil
Rhodesia had very few friends borrowing
some unofficial support from Portugal
has the oil imports in South Africa
because obviously Britain's blockade of
this one port was incredibly expensive
and also incredibly ineffective because
as it turns out Africa has more than one
port from Rhodesia could simply get oil
from South Africa whilst international
governments denounced Rhodesia's
existence as being illegitimate you
should know that British and American
public opinion at the time was extremely
supportive so after the Declaration of
Independence opposition groups in
Rhodesia turned to political violence
but first the primary opposition was
ZAPU the Zimbabwe African people's union
which then splintered and was eclipsed
by Zanu
which stood for the Zimbabwe African
National Union which was led by a
certain Robert Mugabe
Zann who was a communist group which had
received training in China as well as
equipment and support from the Soviet
Union the Rhodesian government received
some support from Portugal
it was heavily reliant on South African
weapons and material Rhodesia also saw a
sizeable inward migration from South
Africa as well as receiving veterans
from the Vietnam War mostly Americans
and Australians
the ongoing conflict became known as the
bush war and to put it mildly
it was absolutely brutal in the early
1970s the scale of the war increased
massively and despite their small
population the white Rhodesians were
able to maintain their hold in the
country for 15 years which given the
embargo and hostile neighbors was more
than most would have expected however
given the support that the guerrillas
were getting alongside their growing
numbers meant that for Rhodesia total
victory became ever more difficult
eventually the defences started to crack
and white civilian deaths increased
which in turn led to emigration to South
Africa less available families meant
less taxes and less soldiers which meant
less ability to safeguard which led to
more emigration you get the idea
in the end Smith pushed for a settlement
to end the war but in a way that gave
white people in Rhodesia greater
authority than the population share
would suggest in the end he reached what
was called the internal settlement with
opposition groups who were led by Abu
Musa Rea WA the settlement was backed by
a whites-only referendum and in 1979 the
first universal election was held which
saw misery were become Prime Minister
and shortly after this the country was
renamed his imbaba Rhodesia Mugabe and
the other rebels saw this as nothing
more than a sham and vowed to keep
fighting Britain refused to accept this
election as legitimate and so him as a
rebel met with its government to propose
a new transition period this led to the
Lancaster House agreement which saw
Zimbabwe Rhodesia revert to British rule
briefly until new elections could be
held in 1980 the first internationally
recognised general election was held
which for Mugabe went comfortably it was
shortly after this that Zimbabwe
Rhodesia simply became Zimbabwe and thus
the short-lived minority rule nation was
no more I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching with the
special thanks to my patreon supporters
who you can see on screen here and with
an extra special thanks to James
Bissonnette David archaeologists party
boy Coe Danny Maloney Colin Castleman
Rob Waterhouse are in the white Michael
Reynolds H Wayne Emperor Chris wicker
Gustav Swan Gareth
Turner spinning three plates David
Silverman Winston k-word Maggie packs
Kowski Christian check' Anthony Beckett
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell and Ike